So in the US all these changes took
place mostly in the first half of the
20th century, a little beyond. And so
they're basically invisible to us now,
which is why we look at our food system
and we think it's normal, but we're
actually seeing a food system that is
completely distorted by refrigeration.
And what's interesting is if you go to a
place that has only just refrigerated or
is still refrigerating, you can see those
shifts take place. Which is why I went to
China to visit the the factory of
the frozen dumpling mogul who brought
frozen food to China. This is the frozen
dumpling factory. He was a surgeon and
when Deng Xiaoping said, "Oh, you know some
people are going to get rich," this
surgeon decided he would like to be one
of those. And so he harvested some parts
from some of the hospital machinery and
built a freezer system. He was already
famous in the neighborhood for his
homemade dumplings, and he just started a
a dumpling factory. But what's amazing is
when you go there you can see the same
things play out that played out here. So
there was an issue
initially, a very intense distrust, and
there still is amongst a certain
generation when I talk to folks about:
could refrigerated and frozen food
be good? Could it really be okay? And
the frozen dumpling mogul told me that
actually the drip right there on the
dumpling is very important. That
signified freshness. They tried to sell
the dumplings in a package without
the drip, and they weren't selling
and the drip somehow sort of
communicated a freshness to folks.  I visited people who are
breeding Chinese vegetables to be cold
storage-tolerant, so their vegetables are
changing in real-time, their diets are
changing, where things are grown is
changing. This is a big Chinese
government project called the South-to-
North Vegetable Transfer that is
shifting
where things are grown. These are Chinese
apples going out to the world. It's
changing where food is sold, so wet
markets are turning into Walmarts, and
that changes how often people shop. It
changes the layout of their houses. It
changes the layout of cities. So you
could see all of those things kind of
changing in real-time. And what's crazy
about China is, so in 2010, the Chinese
government made refrigeration part
of their 12th Five-Year Plan. They were
like, "We are going to refrigerate." And
being China, they just did it. And so it
has, in the past 10 years, the amount of
refrigerated space in China has grown by
more than 20 times. It's just
exploded. And yet still, Chinese people
have less than a third of the cold
storage space of an average American per
capita. So it's still happening. And it's
happening now in India and it's
happening with Chinese funding in Africa.
So the world is refrigerating at speed.
And a lot of people are like, "Well, this
is a good thing," right? Because diets
improve, people have access to fresh
vegetables and dairy and more animal
protein. That's exciting.
Farmers are not stuck selling all their
harvests when it comes in. They can
export, they can make money.
And then the big thing
that people say is, well, food waste, right?
When you don't have a cold chain, you
lose a lot of food. So in a country like
India, where there isn't a robust cold
chain and estimates are that at
least 40% is lost at
the farm stage, basically before it ever
gets anywhere close to the consumer. In
America, where we have an amazing cold
chain, well we waste 40 percent on the
consumer end. So the cold chain people,
refrigeration boosters like to say it
prevents food waste, but I think it's a
little more nuanced than that. It kind of
just shifts where it happens. And maybe
makes it easier to fix? I don't know,
maybe not. This actually strikes me as
harder to fix in a lot of ways.